former director of military operations
in the ministry of Defense air marshall
Edward Stringer great to see you as
always uh Edward so can you let's touch
on this first point so the US has ruled
out sending Jets is that is that to be
expected why are they making that
decision
I think they're making a decision now
for for two reasons uh Biden has always
been sensitive one could argue quite
cautious about making sure that he
doesn't send what might be seen as
advanced offensive weaponry and
therefore allow Putin the out of being
able to claim that he's up against the
whole of NATO and there are a few things
as obviously and totemically American as
the as as the F-16 and so he will he
will see sending f-16s as possibly
escalatory as president uh macron put it
but there's another reason as well and
that's because to get the best out of
something like the F-16 NATO NATO air
pair runs things called combined air
operations and that involves refueling
aircraft Airborne radar platforms
electronic warfare aircraft etc etc to
get the best out of the X F-16 and
deliver Air Supremacy if you don't have
that entire package then the F-16 really
is little better than the mig-29s or the
Sukhoi 27s that the ukrainians already
operate so to really make a difference
in this world would have to be that full
service offering not not just the Jets
what what difference do those two
options make yeah if you were to put the
whole package forward and that would be
very difficult to do to take the
Ukrainian Air Force in its current size
and train it on all of those aircraft
and give them all and want you to do
that we'd be really back where we were
at the start of this conflict because
that would now look like us running a a
no-fly zone and you will remember the
political arguments why why that was
unacceptable at the time so if you do
just gift the F-16 yes it will help
Ukrainian Air Force of course because
you'll be giving them replacement
aircraft but it won't be a game changer
you're just giving them more of what
they got and they'll be able to do what
they do now a little bit better and so
why the sort of different tactic when it
comes to aircraft compared to to tanks
from certain uh Western countries
well if you look at those two tests I
used you can see actually there was a
problem with the Optics and certainly
Chancellor Schultz didn't want to send
just leopards forward where the Optics
then would have been a very obviously
German main battle tank sweeping across
the plains towards Russia and he
wouldn't send the lepers until the
Americans said they would send as you
see here on the screen behind their
their M1 Abrams tanks but the second
condition isn't the same because sending
tanks to the Ukrainian Army which is
bigger it's more organized relative to
to to its Air Force and it's
demonstrated it can conduct the
equivalent of combined air operations
the all-arms battle on the ground
therefore ISS it will be able to
integrate these slightly more
sophisticated tanks it will be able to
make best use of them and they will make
a difference as always thanks so much
thank you